if i had to create a law that everybody  in the world had to follow say if i'm a  president of united states united states  at least the united  states what would i do every single  month here's what i would do every  single month every single month i would  have  a set of books that every everybody  would need to read and submit their  paper  and i'd put a scholarship behind it and  i would go specifically on educating  people on the concepts of money and  mindset because  for whatever reason we're not doing that  and it's not a tough thing to do  i i can't think of the last time a  president recommended a book to read  from stage  you know i just think education and not  education from a school standpoint  education from the standpoint of you  reading a set of books there'd be a  monthly book club if i was a president  that'd be for sure